hey this is the watch of a Collider and
I am here with the awesome folks man
sort of trust thank you all so much for
coming in I super appreciate it thanks
for having us
yeah so we are super appreciate
appreciate you before we get started
here at South by Southwest the only
reason I get to do stuff like this is
because of our great sponsors you might
remember this from Sundance and Britney
sure right it's not the Kia it was Kia
wrote and we kept saying IKEA he was
idea that make sense and we promoted
both in the end but today we are have
you ever driven Ascalon Ascalon yeah
this the IKEA lon it's a great car it's
not a real name of a card let's go on
but I want to give a huge thank you to
Blue Moon and all men's supper sweet and
all of our great sponsors you can see an
amazing Gila yeah I just want to say
thanks to everybody in the court council
right apparently it is also true we do
need more cork that's true we have to do
more heavy drinking you've only got
about a [ __ ] cords got a minimum and
if you want flea market no but any time
these moment like to get a glass box and
fill it with corks apon just look at
marks right take control right I'm the
problem is it's like a murderer's row of
people that can improvise and I'm like
oh I'm in deep [ __ ] like all I can do is
laugh right by the way
so most people watching this interview
will not have seen the movie yet
I hate asking the stupid generic thing
but can you talk a little bit about what
is the elevator pitch of this film you
know what mark you do a good job with
that
I learned mine from you movie is about a
man who he owns a pawn shop in a couple
of women come in with an item that is as
he's told
in the pitch to buy the item could
actually change the way we see and
interpret American history and it's a
sword that's all he's good and it's in
Birmingham Alabama one of the things I
really appreciated about this film is
you guys are bringing up the whole
conspiracy thing conspiracy theories and
it seems to me right now that facts no
longer matter I think you're part of it
you're addressing something that's going
on like on the Internet you can find
people that believe anything anything
that's very correct and so I wanna know
if you could touch on that a little bit
and also from what I understand this
film came about as you wanted to work
together or something along those lines
yeah we uh we met on as I was a guest on
his podcast and very soon thereafter
what directed a couple episodes of his
IFC show Maren and we found that we we
actually worked well together took a
little bit of time to gain his trust I
would give him a note you know every
note I gave him actually he would just
immediately shoved me down and then
eventually take the note and realize
maybe I wasn't just [ __ ] with him but
you know this is something that happens
in all of my relationships in life
eventually if people tolerate my wall of
hostility and defensiveness I will show
them that I'm not that hostile and
defensive yeah yeah and he'll start
going to the bathroom outside yes I just
happened to be in this case a director
and write in an actress situation so
anyway we've built a little bit of trust
and we decided we wanted to keep trying
to work together and then this thing
this show called glow it booked me to be
a director on one of the episodes that
happened to be the Magnus opus episode
for his character and he wasn't even
cast until months later after I was
really sorry Dippet us that
that happened so I ended up directing a
bunch of clothes and um then he asked me
direct his comedy special and we started
writing a movie together but that was
going really slowly and I said I just
want to get on set with you with the
movie and he said okay we'll go write a
movie and I'll give you two weeks in my
time and we can shoot it and so we shot
in 12 days and I wanted to be improvised
and so I got these brilliant improvisers
together and somehow that all happened
they all agreed to come to Birmingham
for 12 days and we shot it and there
there you go
I after seeing the movie I am so
impressed you did this in 12 days me too
16 day movie shut about 25 IM curious
though because there's such there's
really good banter and some
back-and-forth and i want to know how
much from what I understand with like
Curb Your Enthusiasm they will go in
with like a little bit of an outline and
then make it up I'm curious how was it
also a plot heavy film like I had I had
some pretty high concept stuff I wanted
to cover so there there are some scenes
where it was pretty heavily outlined er
what I was asking him to do was
difficult cuz I wanted him to find their
way through the beats of the scene and
to come up with all the dialogue but
then could you just make sure to include
this little fact and this thing that's
gonna be a breadcrumb to lead us to
somewhere down the road you know so it
was very I had to like insert myself a
lot it very obnoxiously and a lot of
times but there were other times that
they could just riff on these little
sidebars and create their own little
backstories and and so it was it was
kind of a balance between those two and
like there's a scene with a time in that
was almost code totally scripted but it
was just sort of loose so it really it
shifted we had a like a 45-page
scriptment we called it where some
scenes were more outlined than others
and sometimes it just said there in the
back of the van and they get to know
each other and then it turns this 9 hour
you know just marathon of them doing
brilliant monologues scriptment scripts
commitment yeah it's like half treatment
half script it's people say that I use
it I don't know if I invented it I would
take credit but I don't think I want to
give Lynn props to because she called us
sometimes
like wrangling cats like wrangling all
of us together we're all as you can tell
by this interview we will take over and
just talk talk talk talk and she had to
be on top of so much like every single
scene the tone and what she was going
for and we were so lost but game I feel
like is it appropriate yeah way to put
it but you're so good at what you do and
the still wouldn't have come obviously
without you but I'm saying perhaps you
thank you thank you ma'am so so if I can
do a follow-up so an example of a scene
that I'm curious about is there's a
scene where the sword is in your pawn
shop and you guys are all figuring it
out and your character comes in as like
a representative of someone and so like
when you're walking in right there -
does everyone know what you're gonna do
or are you walking in and sort of just
going for you we know he's there because
of the sword yeah no idea what the
person is gonna have to leave at some
point yeah he's going to walk in look at
the sword and say yeah we'll get back to
you on this and then leave know about
the glove because it's all improv like
we don't know what the scenes gonna be
we also like sort of the idea is we know
somebody is going to come in we don't
know who's walking in the door I know
that this actor is coming in the door
and I had I barely worked with I think I
worked with you one day on something a
long time ago yeah yeah the Martin Starr
thing that remember that anyway I didn't
know who's gonna walk in the door this
hot ball of fire comes waltzing in like
knows everything put it can I take it
out of the scabbard can I take the sword
out of this guy throwing all this like
sword lingo around had on a blue glove
like new not like had solar and women's
sunglasses and we were like what we
first of all we're sorry for everything
we've been doing because this is the
level that we've gotta like now get to
it was unblocking
that about every because I thought about
that with you guys when you'd start
talking I go oh [ __ ] I have to get up to
there
that's so funny when everyone was
talking I was like when is this gonna
stop they were all worried about levels
I was like I've had enough of all the
levels March inner dialogue is isn't it
well I don't know the inner dialogue is
he's also his outer dialogue which is
can I talk now and but then would also
he's got this look on his face like he
has somewhere better to be all day and
we're holding him up Toby was in
character the entire shoot as well and
they were terrified of him be Toby was
walking around just being like man these
people bear stop touching me I'm gonna
freak out and I'm like who is this
psychopath and towards the end of the
movie he got deeper into the character
like you it became harder to understand
him very swampy accent different
language like what's happening to be
transforming into some sort of swamp
plant so I'm curious when you are
shooting a scene like this with this
many actors and it's improved how many
cameras are you setting up to capture
this well that was the thing and that
was why it was so amazing that we chose
gonna be like in 12 days because we had
two cameras and the other improv I've
made other improvised movies but they
all had like two people scenes so you'd
have one camera on one person one camera
the other person this was at least four
to eight people per scene so the
coverage alone I mean we had a lot of
dueling pairs so I would do a lot of
dueling two shots and have which is I
think with comedy it's great to have two
people on screen anyway at the same time
because there's chemistry that you can
you know you can if you get in singles
it's you kind of lose it but um but I
would want to cover singles as well and
it was just a lot of phases and a lot of
lines and so they did have to recreate
moments and and kind of redo the scene
just because we didn't have enough
cameras you know but any more than two
anyway you would have had to compromise
the lighting so much that it would have
been you know and the angles and stuff
and I lines it wouldn't really have
worked but yeah it was it was it was it
was not an easy thing every day my my ad
and I my assistant director and I at the
end of the day would just look at each
other going how are we doing this I have
idea how we're doing this but our DP was
incredible and yeah everybody talk shop
I'm gonna tell you something uncle Eider
which is the site you're visiting right
now we can actually talk about this I
see geeks and it's a bunch of cinephiles
it's where we always say it's worth
cinephiles and fandom meat oh well I'd
like to add that I generally know when
my coverage begins not only doing it
when the camera is actually on you are
too and not my coverage before where I'm
just acting the [ __ ] out of something
they're like alright we're gonna do your
coverage now mark my goal was just
happening oh you weren't on camera I've
done that but so out of that right and
so now are you more likely to like be it
like if if we look acting between a 1
and a 10 when you're not on in the
coverage are you like at a 5 and then
you bring it to the 10 I still really
not clear when I'm not in the coverage
well that's what's great about improv
again is that you have to you have to
really be engaged especially if there's
two cameras because everybody's on all
the time you can't like just kind of you
know dial it in because you're always on
camera well there's a funny story that
if I can add there's a a funny story
that James L Brooks once told me in my
garage about Nicholson it was either
Brooks or maybe it was Rob Reiner but no
is like Nicholson I think it was on I
don't know if it was a few good men or
one of the or one of Brooks's movies but
he would he would stay for the other eye
he would always just act with the other
actor even if he wasn't on camera which
is a lot to ask of a huge movie star I
guess but he would always give it a
hundred percent and I don't know which
directors said this to him he said you
know you don't have to you don't have to
really show up that much Jack because I
just love to act so yeah you say he
loved doing it awesome that he wanted to
be in it that's why you told us no I'm
not I always show up I'm a very good
receiver some people call that being a
generous actor that's right
[Laughter]
I am very generous give me a bad name
here because he clearly didn't
understand the incredible character work
I was dealing on this movie we saw it
you had to keep a straight face yeah you
had to hold the thing down like an
anchor yeah you were the straight man
thank you huh you were the straight man
Streetman it gives a lot of laughs um I
know I'm almost out of time with you
guys and but I am very curious about the
editing process on something like this
because editing process just it was the
no editing it was just all I'm just
curious um Tyler cook is freaking genius
and he let me basically move into his
house with him this this summer every
day i sat with his dogs behind him and
we just laboured away our first cut of
this film was over two and a half hours
long and it was all wall-to-wall funny
incredibly great and I never thought we
would get it under two hours and it's
now down to 88 minutes and it actually
just got sharper and funnier and funnier
and funnier but the actual little bits
of gold that are lying around that
cutting room floors is painful to
consider it really is I was gonna say
I'm like so with when it's eventually on
like a home video thing are you are you
well you know what I mean we're gonna
put it on a VHS will it have like will
you include like some of theirs god I
would I I have to we just had to tell
ourselves we would do that I don't know
if people even do that anymore I don't
see these are even made or you know but
no you can't do it because it's I know
but it's not it's the tone of it it does
not allow for that I'm gonna I'm just
gonna throw this out there that I run
the site again called Collider and we
have this thing called a YouTube channel
and some other things and after the
movies that we would be happy to oh my
god yeah thank you stuff or deleted
scenes to help promote deal I'm sure
about this I would love to that would be
amazing though seriously it was the only
way that we could actually cut some of
that stuff it was just like it has to
end up somewhere somehow that an
outtakes I'm totally being serious I
have to ask this because I am also a big
fan of glow I think that what you guys
have done is fantastic if I'm not
mistaken did you direct the finale of
this upcoming season I did I just
wrapped on Monday yeah I was gonna say
so
um and I know no spoilers of course but
like what can you tease because the
ending of the last season was a pretty
monumental moment
and the t's of Vegas and you know so
what can you tease about the season
we're in Vegas
absolutely nothing the whole season
takes place in Vegas that's all I
continued opss and I were really the
third time I'd worked with them this
year was crazy it was after you don't
know you had they're never working again
were you cast as a result of or just
like no casting brought you in no I mean
I completely you know I gave him a big
thumbs up when they said what's it like
I think I can tell you a little
something is that and I think two of the
episodes Toby has a beard yeah one of us
is mirrored and then there's not a beard
yeah you guys are giving a lot away here
you're gonna get big trouble and also my
character huge spoilers no he doesn't
die I'm like the word that the Vegas
thing was what's interesting about glow
this season is that because the show is
set if we go to Vegas with it but it is
a set stage show you there's a bigger
opportunity now to sort of explore the
characters you know outside of you know
creating a wrestling show or doing
wrestling matches because they want the
show to be set do you dig what I'm
saying completely so so everybody you
get to know the little pockets of people
a little more everyone sort of on and it
does feel a little bit like a new whole
new show because the the the setting is
so different and and everybody gets to
kind of just be a new self or something
it's very it's a pretty compelling
season we're gonna like it
I listen it's easy I know it's a huge
hit for the for Netflix and you know I'm
I'm a fan and I know so many of us at
Collider or huge fans and before I run
out of time I just have to do the
individual thing Congrats on Brittany
runs a marathon for the people that have
not seen it yet when does it come out
what's the story what's going on still
waiting to hear but I'm sure it's this
year yeah
do you know not no time so they haven't
told you like summer fall yeah so you
know but you can't say I don't know what
do you know
you uh not to go there right for people
because you know just for people that
are watching Britney runs a marathon
with one of my favorite films at
Sundance it's so awesome
I hope people get to see it I know it
was a huge sale you know it's fantastic
I can't wait to see it you kind of
should I mean you guys are friends now
ask you guys other questions and I'm so
sorry that I that we're out of time yeah
and now we're gonna give you fresh use I
know I'm so upset John bass I just have
to shout him out
zero zero box tunnel because my feet
were dying and there's free shoes here
now at the event we were late venmo I'm
expecting a Ben mo oh great thank you
Steve for having when I was gonna say
everything out so we are coming in again
thank you to all of our sponsors for
answers thank you he's freaking tequila
Thank You beer seriously and human and
so more frames thank you thank you